all right Lisa
Lisa where'd you grow up where are you
from originally uh born and raised in
Riverside California
I grew up amongst the Orange Groves and
I'm working class neighborhood tell me
about your family
well if you saw my parents they look
like they came straight out of a 1950s
magazine
they look innocent
and safe but they were anything but safe
tell me yeah so
um I'm the youngest of three my brother
and sister are older
they were adopted because my mom
couldn't have kids which is fine I'm a
miracle
but that became an issue in our family
because my parents are dysfunctional and
made it an issue but
my earliest memory is
of
I guess I was about five and I was
looking over my mom which I know now she
had attempted suicide but
um
I didn't know was what was going on then
but my parents divorced when I was five
and they were very contentious with each
other and you know put us in the middle
and you know try to make each other look
bad
um but my mom I guess went away for a
little bit my grandmother came and
stayed with us about the only time I saw
my grandmother in my childhood
and
um my mom came back a party woman she
was a singles woman at this point so it
became all about the singles world and a
woman a single mother with issues is a
pedophile magnet
and that's exactly what my mother was
and
so the first clear memory I have of
being sexually abused was from John
and he was super helpful to my mom came
around the house and you know did
whatever she wanted and my mom thought
it was a good idea to work evenings so
we were alone in the evenings
and John would come and see me in the
evenings and
so
I you know pedophiles are always looking
for opportunities besides the fact that
I was there alone without a parent I was
starving for affection my own father
wouldn't give me affection I asked him
for hugs and he was just very cold and
distant
and uh so John John was there to give me
attention and ice cream and one day he's
like Lisa let's go get ice cream
and uh
so I'm like yeah I like ice cream let's
go get it
but instead of going to Thrifty's Ice
Cream he went into a field and it was
different in the field
than at home
and all I remember really is just the
the look in his eyes changing to
I don't know more primal
and just being in his car with him and
yeah at the end he looks at me and he
says do you love your mom
yeah you know I'm five I love my mom
um do you want your mom to live yeah
yeah and he said if I say anything about
what happened then
you know she'll die so but I I didn't
know what to say I don't have words I
don't know what penises vagina sex
petting I don't know anything so I don't
know what to say
um so I didn't say anything and the next
day or the next week he came back over
brought me crayons and a coloring book
and
so you know I'm excited for that and I
start coloring and he starts to proceed
to molest me and he has his hands up my
my little dress and my sister comes
pounding in the living room and like
she's pissed she's like five years older
than me so she's a 10 year old girl and
she's like what is going on and looking
at me you know like it's my fault
and I just I don't know what's going on
what's going on I don't again I don't
have words for it and
um so
John pulls his hand out and jumps up and
leaves
the next day or so my sister has my mom
and John gathered around the kitchen
table and they call me in and she says
Lisa what happened and I again I don't
have words I'm avoiding looking at John
I
I have nothing to say so that's it but
it was my sister who was angry and she
ended up telling my father
when my father came over
he
said Lisa I understand that you know
John molested you and just you know just
don't make a big deal about it don't
make a big deal
and you know at five like okay I I don't
even know you know a five-year-old brain
what's going on making a big deal about
it so
um
so that's that's my first experience
with a pedophile that my mom
um connected with a guy named Larry
and Larry felt that it was his you know
moral obligation to raise us girls to
not be frigid when we grew up I remember
him telling me that like you know I
don't want you to be frigid when you get
older and I I don't know what frigid
meant yeah I was like refrigerator I
don't know and
um so it's my brother's sister and
myself and my mom and he thought that he
would start by showing us uh how to not
be frigid I guess by going to nudist
camps so Glenn Eden Sun Club
um was a place that he took us which is
super awkward and we didn't want to get
naked and we protested and it was gross
and weird but
you even though it's a family nudist
camp nobody can have their clothes on so
um so here we are there you know a bunch
of kids naked just awkwardly looking at
each other and I was kind of freaked out
because I didn't know I'm trying not to
look but why does that man look
different from that man I have no idea
um but we we try to have fun and you
know it turns out that nudist camps are
pedophile magnets
go figure and there's a
pool for little kids and then the bigger
pool you had to earn your dolphin tag
for that so in the little pool was
manned by I don't know the hairy guy and
he you know us kids would line up and he
would take turns you know throwing us
into the deep end and but you know
accidentally not accidentally grab you
know my crotch area or something I'm
sure other kids he did that too as well
and then in the big pool was a guy named
We nicknamed the doctor he wore goggles
and we would be swimming and he would
swim underneath and we just knew you
know so we like
part the water and try to get out
so that was a regular experience going
to Glen Eden
with Larry and my mom and then when we
would get home
he felt that it was important apparently
to actually show us what sex was again I
I don't remember that word being used
but he and called me in the room once
and I know now what was happening they
were having sexual intercourse and just
told me to sit down and watch
and then another time
um
on our kitchen table he calls all of us
kids in and is having sex with my mother
on the kitchen table and gives my
brother a camera to take pictures
and you know we're just goofy awkward
kids it's
I don't know so um he proceeds to you
know this goes on and
sometimes we went to his place and when
we went to his place it seemed like he
liked to take my sister alone in the
room with him and my mom and my brother
and I just bummed around his place and
then
I know that I was alone with them at
least once all I remember is
um
him showing me a sex toy
him and my mom and then afterwards I
knew what it was and how to use it at
five
and so
that wasn't all you know Larry asked me
one day to make him a bath and he was
going to show me how to bathe him
so I do to flea went to the bathroom now
Larry had a problem with my brother my
brother was a little cusser okay my
brother's about three and a half years
older than me I guess he didn't like
Larry and so he's told him something
like [__] you Larry you know and Larry
was like
no this was not okay with him and so
he's naked I'm standing by the bathroom
my brother comes out and he grabs my
brother by the ankles and he picks him
up and he starts dipping his head in the
toilet like he's waterboarding him and
I'm just I'm just heartbroken and
terrified for my brother and um
helpless
and so
um
then my brother runs off you know in
shame and humiliation and Larry says
Lisa come in here and proceeded to show
me how to bathe him you know in all
areas
so that relationship didn't last even
though my mom blamed us kids you know
good I'm glad Larry's gone however the
early sexualization and the
um the violence the anger you know just
rolled downhill and who's at the bottom
so my brother I know my siblings are
victims as well but um
what ended up happening is it started to
become not just my brother but a
neighborhood game like let's pants Lisa
so it would go from
yeah
we're playing hide and go seek or
something and now it's time to pounce
Lisa and so I would start running and I
would always do my best to get away but
I was never successful and we'd end up
in in a room in the house and they'd rip
off my clothes one boy on each arm and
leg and ripped my legs open and start
experimenting poking laughing ignoring
ignoring me and um
you know that went on I don't know how
long I'm thinking until my stepdad came
into our lives but
you know once you are kind of labeled as
in my mind I think of it as like you're
be you're used so fair game you know so
I was like fair game for the boys in the
neighborhood I couldn't just ride my
bike down the street sometimes I could
but sometimes I couldn't and Keith and
Craig would grab me off my bike and drag
me into their house or come in my
backyard and run you know would try
to get me to do sexual things with him
it was just a um
chaotic mess of a neighborhood and
things weren't were bad they were bad
one day um
before school there was a knock at the
door and I I answered it and as this guy
with this big smile Fuller brush
salesman
and um he's like is your mom home and
I'm like yeah and I anyway I came home
that day and he was still there and so
this guy became my stepdad
and he he was my best parent he could
have been a pedophile but that wasn't
his thing he liked my mom
and um Larry actually
not Larry Ray
um
tried to parent us and so he uh I pretty
much put a stop to my brother's assaults
and
um
I guess I cried a lot as a child
as he reminded me as an adult like Lisa
you would always be crying and but what
but Ray what Ray did is he would come in
the room and he would pick me up and
Carry Me
to my mom's bed and lay me next to her
and then he would go lay on the couch
and
she never
gave me a hug or brushed my hair out of
my eyes or anything like that but just
Rey giving me that nurturing
was very special it gave me a sense of
what real affection for my parent would
look like
unfortunately he was a Merchant Marine
and so he would be gone like six months
out of the year and
um
so when he was gone things are worse but
I was always there dropping him off at
the Port of Los Angeles and picking him
up
we had a good time together
um
he was Street Smart you know so we got
schooled street-wise ways but
anyway so that was I was nine when he
came into our lives
and he left when I was 12 but in the
meantime while when when he was
on the ship I guess my sister went back
East to visit our grandmother and on the
way back she met a couple on a train Don
and Jody and uh I guess they found out
that
they're talking to this teenage girl
that oh my gosh we go to nudist camps
too that we she went to nudist camps
they go to nudist camps and somehow it
became the plan
that they're going to take me to nudist
camp I'm 11 years old and my mom's like
Lisa your sister met this couple and
they're going to take you to Glen Eden
and I said no I don't want to go I don't
want to go to Glen Eden
I don't want to get naked in front of
people again but she said you're going
so I'm in my bedroom and they come in to
the house and I hear them laughing and
then yucking it up in the kitchen and my
mom calls me out
and they're like oh you're Lisa okay
well let's go you know and I'm sure Jody
saw my hesitation she's like come on
let's race Let's Race to the truck and
so you know I'm I'm always looking for
an opportunity to run or something
um play a game and so we race to the
truck and I'm sure she beat me and then
they're like here sit in the middle and
so Don's here Jody's here I'm in the
middle and they have a pack of marbles
on the dashboard and um she's like you
want a cigarette and so I had been a
regular smoker of cigarettes and shot
since I was eight but I had never smoked
in front of adults and of course I drank
and smoked weed when I could as well but
I'm I'm like you sure it's okay for me
to smoke with you guys yeah it's fine no
problem so I was like puffing away on
the way to Glen Eden and um
so then we get there
and you have to get naked again so of
course it's a race who can get naked the
quickest you know same scenario awkward
place uncomfortable
and then they take me to their apartment
and they're like Lisa by the way the
rules are the same in our apartment as
at Glen Eden it's a no closed zone so
it's a game as soon as the door is
closed who can get their clothes off the
fastest right
okay so now we're all naked in the
apartment but you know they had Atari
they had cigarettes I didn't have to go
figuring out a way to get them and they
had alcohol
sometimes marijuana
um
but I guess it was okay I was feeling
like
you know maybe it's okay
and uh I don't know the next day or the
next week Jody uh was at work and I had
to be alone with Don I want to be alone
with Don I wanted to be with Jody she
was cool she was a basketball player and
um
but we went shopping and then we went to
go pick Jody up and as we're waiting he
says to me Lisa
your sister said that you want to have
sex with me
and
I'm freaked out I'm petrified
um
thinking oh and oh my gosh you're like
I'm in trouble like I did something
wrong I gave the wrong impression I'm
11. he's like 39 maybe 40 and I said no
no yeah I'm sorry I don't know why she
said that and
um
so he's like it's it's okay it's all
right that you want to have sex with me
but I don't want to have sex with you
and so then you know my mind starts
racing and I think and my 11 year old
brain that Jody's gonna be mad
um and I don't want her to be upset so I
asked him please please don't tell Jody
and um
so uh he just kind of smirks at me but
agrees he agrees and I um
feel some relief
but as soon as she gets in the car he
said hey guess what Lisa wants to have
sex with me
and
she's immediately says great yeah no
problem
and I
don't want that I'm
what can I say I I don't know
but we drive on and we get back to their
apartment
and you know all pedophiles are
philosophers you know don't be frigid
and like you know they're going to do me
favors and my mom's crazy Lisa you know
your mom's crazy right and and Jody told
me you know if your dad if you had a
good relationship with your dad you'd
want to have sex with him
and I asked Don like do you do you want
me to call you Dad
uh but he just smirked
and so they started engaging me in
sexual activities but I was definitely
reluctant and um so Jody's like come on
takes me by the hand like you all you
have to do is watch this time
and so I'm just laying in bed and while
they're having sex watching and then it
proceeds to dawn like comes and holds me
and then it proceeds to engaging me in
sexual activities touch oral sex
but Don wanted me to voluntarily say
please please be my first but I was not
that was not my interest I was not
interested in that so part of the way
that he tried to get me to be
comfortable with that idea was he had me
watch Pretty Baby
the movie where Brooke Shields was a
child and she was molested in the film
um it's child pornography she's naked in
it she's auctioned off her virginity at
12 years old it's a [__] house
everyone's happy of course everything's
great and in the movie the whole time
she's totally fine she's great she's
happy it doesn't affect her
um and that's definitely what
I I got the message it's not supposed to
affect me it's not a big deal it's only
a big deal if you make it a big deal
right
so I don't I I don't know Don's brain I
don't know but it became a regular
uh occurrence him sitting down with me
watching Pretty Baby and um during this
time
you know he's touching me sometimes
Jody's there he's touching Jody and you
know sexually and
always like indoctrination and you know
part of his thing was you know Lisa it
would actually be you know difficult for
me I would be doing you a favor and you
know once it happens like it's no big
deal and he even introduced me to a girl
he said that he did the same thing
foreign she's fine
um
so whatever
they took me on a um
three-state camping trip just the two of
them and I and one day let me ask how
did your mom
consent to all of this
I don't know
she just told me to go with them
she didn't ask me what happened she knew
we were going to nudist camps
and that I would go to their house just
about every weekend for a couple years
and then on this camping trip so
I'm assuming my father consented as well
at least by omniscient right he wasn't
checking up
so I don't know
anything more than that
crazy
but um so we go on this camping trip and
you know back then this is before the
internet and before
um
cell phones and all that but he had his
projector and he had pretty baby
and we're watching it at a campground
and
whatever so one day we were at Flagstaff
Arizona and it's the daytime and I wake
up and I'm
drunk or something
and so I I don't understand I'm not
orientated and so I kind of get out of
the camper and I stumble around I'm
looking for Don and Jody and I found
find them and they um
like Lisa what are you doing you know
get back in there you're going to get us
in trouble okay
um but you know thinking back now I do
wonder what was in the alcohol sometimes
um
but you know consciously you know he
wanted me to to make choices so like I'm
full on board right
but
um sometimes it wasn't just me there
there was sometimes other girls
and one day Don says
I'm going to take you to be a model and
I was like no no it's okay you know I'm
I think of myself I I was like I was
thought I was fat and ugly I'm an ogre
you know I look back now pictures of me
and I'm just a skinny kid
not sexy I
was just a awkward
the 12 13 year old you know but
um he's like no no I'm gonna take you
girls and we'll get your picture taken
so
we go and I'm in the back of his truck
with a shell on it and just kind of
waiting at the time you know like I
never knew where I was going
uh I knew I was in Santa Ana with them I
knew I was in Riverside back home that's
about it I could get around town and
Riverside walking
but uh I'm in the back of the truck and
I I hear a voice
and the voice has
um memorized how to get there
I'm just like whatever shake it off and
I'm just in the back of the pickup truck
and I hear it again it's kind it's firm
and it says memorize how to get there
so I do I open up the window at the side
of the shell and I'm looking and I'm
like 7th Street 7th Street 14th Street
14th Street you know I'm memorizing how
to get there and then we pull up and
like I can still see it in my in my head
like a two-story office building stairs
outside that ugly tan bricks and the
studios on the Second Story and so
um
I don't know if it was 319 but anyway so
we kind of rushed up us girls you know
kind of racing each other right
everything's a game and we walk in the
studio and I see this guy sitting there
and kind of a very long almost like a
table desk
but a very long desk and in the middle
of it is a Rubik's Cube
and so I'm like a Rubik's Cube can I
play with it and we met our eyes met and
it was just his look was so cold
and mean
and
I don't know intense that it just kind
of shocked me I looked away and I just
sat down
and I didn't say anything else
just one by one we all got our head
shots clothes clothes on that's it and
um
then we're out of there yeah goodbye
and
the next day it's just me and Don and
Jody at their apartment
and I hear Dawn on the phone with this
photographer somehow I know it's a
photographer and he says yeah yeah Lisa
will do nude pictures
and I was like I don't know I'm always
trying to say no right like no I won't
and he turns and he looks at me with
that similar look like shut up shut up
and points to the couch for me to sit
down
and um
you know again like like Looking Back
Now
there was always a camera out Don always
had a camera and apparently you know
there was probably a lot of pictures of
me naked and they sometimes dressed me
up even pose me but I don't know it was
a game where I didn't really think of it
like voluntarily or something this just
seemed like no I'm not going to
volunteer for that
you could at least ask
um but took me home and I I go to school
for the week now my grades have at this
point completely tanked I'm failing
completely out of Junior High School I
um I did good in elementary school
uh the only class I'm passing is PE
because I love sports and so
um
also
you know kind of like I became like the
Target in the neighborhood I don't know
that carried on you know I would go to
parties with friends older High School
boys and
you know a victim just gets taken
advantage a lot and then I I became the
Target or the the [__] the school sled
literally people called me sled so I'm
the [__] and whatever but but anyway I I
didn't go very much and so
one day I was there and I'm at PE and I
get called to the office now I go into
the office and Miss Brewer usually was
glaring at me he didn't like me because
of my shoddy attendance
but this time she kind of has like a sad
look kind of
compassionate she's like Lisa these are
um detectives are here to talk to you
and
again I just I don't know what the think
or say but
um
we go into a room she's my support
person you know even though she hated my
guts
and they just start asking me questions
do you know Don Gordon Jody Jones
yes
and I don't remember all the questions
but were you naked with them did you
have oral sex did you have sexual
intercourse with his finger and you all
those questions and
um
I I'm not sure you know I if I should be
answering them or not but
confused
anyway at the end detective Mendoza said
um you're going to go in a shelter home
because
your home environment I don't know I
have to investigate it or something like
that which surprised me because
I don't know you're just you're in
denial about your life nothing abnormal
you know
and so
um I'm still in my PE clothes and he's
like well you know we're gonna need to
talk to your mom and it turns out that
day
my mom is actually picking me up usually
I ride my bike to school and
um but she I said well my mom's picking
me up and the school was just letting
out you could hear the Bell it rang and
he's like really okay so he sent the
other detective to go get her and then
she meets with me in the office
and she's like Lisa
and reaches out to me and Embraces me
and says why didn't you tell me
why didn't you tell me
and I just felt like so much shame and
humiliation and tell her what I still I
don't know I didn't know but I know
looking back like why was that so weird
you know but my mom never hugs me
so
that was one reason why that was so
weird
but detective Mendoza took me to shelter
home and
um
was very kind to me he
made sure that I was able to continue to
play sports I was an All-Star catcher
for this girls softball team and I I
don't I didn't know why at the time but
I had to have a sheriff's escort
which was very awkward and uncomfortable
and like I'm in a shelter home now
so I'm always like the weird girl you
know and um
but I was able to play sports which I
was really grateful for and he took me
out to dinner with his family a couple
times and tried to kind of you know like
Lisa it'll be all right you know you can
still have a good life that sort of
thing
one day
a social worker showed up and took me to
Orange County for those detectives to
interview me and
I get there and one detective takes me
in the room and he
says uh so there's this photographer
I guess he knew I don't know how he knew
would I whatever but um he knew about
this photographer and he said you know
Don and Jody said they don't know how to
get there they don't know where he's at
and I was like wait a minute
you know before I had a chance to say I
memorized how to get there he said
and this photographer Lisa is wanted for
killing children
Annie starts to tell me details like a
boy was tied up in a chair and
um
a a girl was found in a couple dumpsters
and I'm not even
it's just
how do you take in that information and
um
so when he finished explaining a little
bit I said well I memorized how to get
there
you said you did I said yeah he's like
let's go right now
and so we went and I'm like 7th Street
14th Street I took him right to the same
Studio
and walked him right up to it and
there's these two big detectives and me
I'm 13 at this time
and they knock on the door
and I'm thinking
okay is this guy gonna end up killing me
because I don't know he's gonna see that
it's me showing
um but there was no answer they didn't
bust down the door
um
we just left
but I always wondered like was he
looking through a people or something I
don't know
and then um they took me back to
Riverside and that was it
you know I think it's a example of how
I always want to be helpful with the
system with you know fighting good
against evil doing the right thing but
victims aren't considered so it would
have been nice for somebody to check on
me and let me know if the photographer
got busted or if he's on the run or what
but nobody ever told me so a few months
later I kind of took this as a sign from
the universe they used to have
editorials back then and it was Hal
fisherman
I'm pretty sure he was talking about
some victim and their courage and
showing
something the detectives and some child
pornography Marine got busted and thanks
to the victim and I was like
wow I wonder you know was that because
of me I have no idea but
um
you know I never heard anything
otherwise
um
but near the end of the summer detective
Mendoza tells me
Lisa I I have to take you back home
I don't want to I feel that your mom is
the worst kind of abuser
but
um
I don't have a choice like they're not
going to let me keep you in the system
so he
I gather my stuff and he drives me home
and he's tries to give me a pep talk I
know he didn't want to do it
but he had to do it and
there I go right back into the home
and you know no therapy no follow-up
nothing
so my family being the family that they
are
I was looked down on not for being a
victim of sexual abuse but for like
especially according to my dad you know
especially if you're a man if you want
to have sex with a man a woman a child
that's fine like that's like the
religion that he lived and that I might
be responsible for somebody getting
busted for that
definitely made him look down on me more
so
and my mom just called me a [__] and my
siblings I don't know they're out of
their minds you know doing their own
things
but I somehow gathered up like the
determination like I'm gonna do good in
ninth grade I'm I'm like I'm not getting
involved with anybody again and I'm
I'm gonna do good in ninth grade and I
looked up to my sister and I she played
volleyball and she was in drama and
choir and I um
so that's what I was going to do that
was my plan and I actually got on on the
honor roll in ninth grade and I tried
out for volleyball having never played
before and fell in love and I got on the
uh I lettered as a freshman
and I was in heaven
sort of I mean home life still sucked
right I'm still getting high every day
drinking when I can whatever I'm a total
smoker
and this guy you know we live like these
people live right behind us longtime
friends and their older son moved back
home
he was cute way older than me I'm not
interested but I did have a crush but
I'm never gonna do anything about that
but anyway he comes around a lot and you
know you get the just long story short
he and my sister like hey let's go for a
ride and that's when I got introduced to
methamphetamines
so uh mess wow
uh he's like Lisa here's some math you
know and uh if you're having a hard time
sleeping duh uh you can come over my
house in the middle of the night and
we'll play games
okay
so
um one night I'm like okay I'm just
gonna go over there and play games
because I'm just like tweaking out of my
brain and
bored
so we did we actually started playing a
game and then before I know it he
started kissing me
and I did I did feel flattered at first
I was like oh my God you know I'm 14 and
like he seems so cool but then it like
progressed really really fast
and became very instructional from him
to me and
then when we were done he's like I'll
see you tomorrow and I
just crawl back out of his window and I
go home and I thought am I naive forever
naive brain
oh my gosh we're boyfriend and
girlfriend
but I'm terrified that people are gonna
find out because I'm the [__] and
there's more confirmation that that's
the case so
um
I told him I said Glenn
um nobody can find out about this
so he's like oh no problem
nobody will find out so that that worked
out for him and he's like you know what
come back over tonight and bring your
volleyball uniform
so um okay
and I I brought my volleyball uniform
and he's like
go ahead and put it on but I'm like
super awkward to change into it which he
thinks is kind of funny you know
and I do and he's
took some pictures of me in my
volleyball uniform and then he had other
outfits to wear and then it became just
naked pictures and you know over time
like it progressed to uh pictures you
know involving sex acts and
you know I started to really get the
impression that you know he's not my
boyfriend and because he's a philosopher
too you know and he would say things
like Lisa you know when you get married
when you're older you know I'll take you
to the wedding chapel and and that
actually hurt my heart because I'm like
I want to marry you
um
and and then when you get divorced I'll
take you to the divorce attorneys and so
it didn't I I didn't want to participate
with him anymore but he couldn't let it
go
but I told him
um
you got to get rid of those pictures you
know if somebody's going to find them
and then I'm going to be confirmed again
a [__] I guess
and he but I stopped I stopped meeting
up with him and he said well Lisa if you
want to get rid of some old pictures
then you can do some new pictures we'll
get rid of 10 pictures you do five new
pictures
and I just
I I didn't want to do that so I just did
my best to avoid him but he's in the
neighborhood and he's coming around my
house and my mom had a boyfriend that
was coming around the house and he's
trying to get me to go to Vegas to be a
prostitute and
just like so I I avoided home as much as
possible and
yes of course you know I'm just like
this clueless young girl victim getting
assaulted at parties and
not not a good situation but just like a
hot mess of course High School
um one quarter on the honor roll and
then you know turns out that
perpetrators don't really care about
your grades or your sports and so
I
um went to continuation school couldn't
hack that and I'm on independent study
but by this time I had a friend I would
hang out at his house Andy we were buds
and there was a guy up there that he was
just 10 years older than me and I was 14
but he told Andy's mom that he wanted
you know more of a relationship with me
and with her encouragement I guess
eventually you know I told her I'm not
interested and I told him I'm I'm just
like trying to hang out you know we'd go
to the beach he'd surf I'd sunbathe and
but anyway by the time I was 15 were
boyfriend and girlfriend but hey at
least he called me his girlfriend but it
was the same situation you know as Glenn
and um
just just not my life was a mess
and I'm
I I had like I didn't
I want it to be sober
but I had no idea how I could ever be
sober and so I'm just cycling through
like weed every day alcohol when I can
of course I'm a total smoker or meth if
I can get it or is your mom using drugs
not that I know of pills
pills
and she still looked like
um
you know she had like that up down the
hair and her perfect makeup and dressed
in business and whatever
our house was always perfectly clean and
she always made sure sometimes we have
to get up in the middle of the night and
clean it and
so my house that's how it looked it was
always in order but
um no I'm just out about doing drugs
and but this guy Bob my boy my boyfriend
um his family was really nice
and they were Christian and they knew
what we were doing but they were still
really nice
you know and
um
they're like hey you can play sports at
the church so I'm like okay any
opportunity to play sports uh because I
really missed out and then they started
just talking to me about prayer and I
always always believing in God and
um but I hadn't heard of the Bible I
mean I'd heard of the Bible but I didn't
know anything about or ten commandments
and stuff so anyway I started praying
more specifically
and I gained strength like I started
going to church and I I was able to just
quit using substances I had like a new
new people to hang out with and I found
like this Inner Strength
somehow to break up with Bob
and I was like wow
um but one day I was praying
actually I guess before I
was able to quit everything anyway I had
a spiritual experience and I knew in
this prayer I had this distinct feeling
that that God said Lisa you can stay on
the path you're on
and my love for you is no less
but you're not going to get sober it's
going to get worse you're gonna die
early be a prostitute or some variation
thereof overdose something
or you can go on this path
and this path is a clean and sober path
where I I don't have to be dealing with
all of these perverts anymore so for me
it's a no-brainer and I went on this
path
and so then
um so basically I just started hanging
out with church people young people in
my age and I was working I was able to
get a diploma but they basically gave it
to me
because I I didn't really earn it
I sort of but not really and
um
I started going to martial arts martial
arts really filled that you know
movement need I had and then um then I
meet my husband
and he's a good Christian guy and he
we started dating in a very different
way than what I was used to and I'm
completely sober now and I'm like
you know he's showing more interest and
in our little world there you know it's
marriage it's the next step and I told
him well like I have this past
and he's like it's okay it doesn't
matter and so we ended up getting
married
and I'm still I'm still clean and sober
but after I had my first son
um bam man the Depression hit
and I I wasn't well
I was so well I didn't really know where
to go for help but I'm like well I guess
I better go to therapy
and
um that was my beginning of trying to
get help and
it was sketchy you know back then there
wasn't now everyone's trauma informed
everybody understands trauma and complex
post-traumatic stress disorder and all
that but back then like
nobody nobody knew that
and
but there were some like I I did go to
like a sexual abuse Recovery Group and
I was like you know I think I want to be
a therapist
and I remember one of the girls saying
you know Lisa everybody wants to be a
therapist in recovery I'm like okay but
I think I really do and so um I decided
to become a therapist and I started with
one class at a time
but that was actually
I I had honestly I was so anxious I had
so much anxiety
um
that I I couldn't complete the first two
classes I had to drop them
but the third class stuck you know and
eventually I just kept going but uh
before I even took my first class
um
I think I had my second son and I get a
call from the Orange County District
Attorney's office
and they asked me if I will testify on
behalf of Don's newest victim I mean out
of the blue
and I'm just trying to live my life
trying to manage my family and I'm my
husband's family we both come from
traumatic histories and
you know it's a huge re-trigger
but they don't ask
hey do you need anything are you okay
it's just like business you're done oh
we don't need you to testify it's over
but it's a complete re-trigger
so about that time too I had decided oh
my God you know like what the hell you
know my childhood
what you know so I I I'm starting to get
in touch with my anger because I can't
let that anger go inwards and be
depression so I have to put the anger
where it belongs
because it doesn't belong on my children
and it doesn't belong on my husband and
it doesn't belong on me so I decided I
was going to confront my abusers
but I I couldn't find most of them I
looked in the phone book you know this
is before the internet but you know I'm
like I think I'm going to confront my
father and so he comes over one day
and I tell them what happened John Larry
Don and Jody and all I mean I know now
thinking back like he should no anyway
um and he's like wow Lisa you had quite
an extensive sex life
and I was
offended and hurt
and then before I had a chance to say
anything he said and children under the
age of three don't remember anything
and I
I didn't say anything about that I was
only talking about John you know
and actually with my dad I remember a
couple times like growing up thinking
because my brother and sister went and
lived with him a couple times
but I remember thinking like
I I would rather be on the streets of LA
than live with my dad
but I don't want to go on the streets of
LA or Vegas or anywhere
um by the grace of God I'm not
um but my father he
um
yeah he liked young boys and he
he was a high school teacher
and so one day
after this experience I was another high
school teacher at the school he taught
at got busted for molesting a boy
and um
I guess I was still naive and I was like
Dad oh my gosh Mr Gerdes got busted for
molesting a boy and he's like
Lisa every boy is going to be
masturbated at some point and I was like
okay
okay you know I never left any of my
sons alone with him ever not once
and I eventually had to cut off that
relationship but my dad you know my dad
was not proud of me becoming Christian
it wasn't my plan I I didn't do it for
anything other than
that just saved me
um and but he knew he knew who I was I
was never rude to him like that I mean
okay I confronted him but you know he
deserved it and uh anyway as an adult he
would say the most awful vulgar things
to me that I won't repeat because I
would feel guilty for putting it in your
head but one one time he said to me Lisa
I was in West Hollywood
and I was going by a pornography uh
theater and I saw your name Lisa bear
it's my maiden name and like did you do
the film like I didn't get a chance to
go in and see it you know because I was
out of time but I totally would have
so
I don't know I guess he just liked the
shock value or something
we decided
at some point that you know I needed to
get out of Riverside and farther away
from my family so we moved up to the
high desert
to Adelanto the armpit of the high
desert and um
it was a it was a big change and it was
good and then
um you know we looked around we were
able to buy our our house in Apple
Valley and it was little that it had a
beautiful view and
so I'm still going to school and yeah
anyway the day after we moved into the
house in Apple Valley
I'm at the grocery store and I have my
youngest son who's a toddler at the time
in the car seat and I see Jody
and I'm like
what
yeah anyway so I
freaking out and I'm like oh my God
please don't let her be my neighbor
you know that's just I just don't want
him to be my neighbor so
um I followed her I waited for her to
come back out I have my poor son in the
car and I'm trying to follow her but she
loses me I don't know I don't think she
knew I was following her right and I
don't know where she went so I knew at
the time Megan's Law you had to go into
the sheriff's office to get information
and they didn't publish their addresses
but I go in and I
um tell them the situation I just want
to make sure she's not my neighbor
and
um
they're like we don't we don't see her
we don't see her on Megan's Law I'm like
but I I know I know the judge said that
she had to register as a sex offender
and
um I said well so she molested me with
this guy Don Gordon and you know they
look him up and they're like okay what
have a seat where did you just move from
and they
um
said that he had been paroled to
Adelanto where I was just living which
is a little town
and
um I remembered like a few months
earlier on the radio like KFI or
something or hearing about like a dawn
Gordon and some other sex offender going
you know being released into a Santa Ana
neighborhood and the the neighbors were
like no we don't want him here you know
kicking him out and so I called the
radio station to try to find out but
they didn't return my call so I put it
out of my head and
um
just moved out of Adelanto my son one of
my sons was still in soccer there
winning soccer team and
yeah so they're like okay we'll have his
parole officer contact you the parole
officer contacts me and
um
comes over to my house and he's like why
didn't you tell us where you live Mike
I did not know I was supposed to tell
you where I live nobody ever told me
anything but basically as a victim of
his or of a sex offender they cannot be
paroled within 25 miles of you
um but I didn't know that and so
it became it became this uh really
negative interaction with the parole
officer because I told him I said you
know okay I guess I realize this is a
less than one percent chance but just in
case just in case Don can you search him
because you can do he can do that at any
time he told me just make sure that he
doesn't have a picture of me or a
picture of my sons
please
because I'm trying not to think
but
you know I'm sure he just thought I was
crazy but he said yeah yeah I'll do that
you know a few weeks pass and
I don't hear any information so I called
him up and I said so did you search him
you know and he didn't even lie and he
said no no I didn't search him
I'm like why you know like you miss that
opportunity like if there was something
there you could have found it now you
know he knows that somebody saw him and
or some I don't know
and
um he's just kind of like has no
communication skills and is treating me
um offensively at this point and so I
asked to talk to his supervisor
and I call his supervisor and I'm crying
and I'm like kind of hysterical and I'm
I'm sorry you know I don't mean to be
crazy but I just want he said he was
going to do it and he didn't do it and
the parole officer supervisor says um
you know what you really should get some
therapy
and um I'm like really wow wow never
occurred to me thank you
um
so I just have to regulate you know he
wasn't in my presence but you know I'm
not gonna lie I definitely had some
violent thoughts towards him and I was
like this just was like this whole mess
and I told him to I said look Jody is
supposed to be registered and you know
California had three strikes and this
would have been her third strike but
anyway they gave her a pass I guess
because she was a female but she then
she had to register and the thing is
about Megan's laws I could
um see where she lived you know after
they upgraded it and where Glenn lived
and it gave me a sense of
power somewhat you know and Don of
course but um
anyway
uh some random police officer in San
Bernardino called and left her address
on my machine and
so I then knew where she lived which of
course was right by the college I was
going to
and also I started to run into her
at Walmart at the doctors
like all the time I and I'm always
dodging and hiding out and grabbing my
kids
and I really don't even realize at the
time how much this is triggering me
except for I am
trying to live my life and I'm not doing
well so I kind of got to the conclusion
where you know what she's going to
reoffend
um and I am obviously not a good mom not
a good wife and so I should just go
kill her and then I'll be in prison my
husband and kids can move on and you
know just crazy thinking and
more than a few times I'm driving around
her neighborhood and just thinking about
it and calling my husband Robert you
know I just feel like this is what I
need to do and he's
talking me down and so
did Orange County District Attorney's
Office care follow up with therapy try
to talk to me help me out in any helpful
way no
the positive that came from it is Don
was put under civil commitment
which is a whole law that if your parole
officer thinks you're going to reoffend
they can do that and then they're like
forced into treatment something like
that but they're housed not in prison
but
a prison you know hospital and so he's
out of the picture and so this whole
time though that I'm running into Jody
it turns out that she actually did
reoffend
how did I find out I found out through
Megan's Law because again why would I
get updates
and
she I don't know if she got extradited
out to Illinois or what but
you can read that it was an offense in
California and anyway whatever
so yes I needed to put the anger where
it belongs but also learning to let go
you know I want to move on with my life
and I do that
trying to do the best we can raising our
family going to school I I became a
therapist
and I feel like I was doing okay you
know
um
and we decided that we needed to move
out of state because our sons the
environment became not the best for them
and the economy took a dump and so we
went to a state where my husband had
gone to school for most of his life grew
up most of his life there and
um
so I couldn't go into private practice
right away I had to work at agencies and
so until that worked its way out and I
was literally a crisis therapist for
children who had just been placed in CPS
care
and at this point I had oh I I used to
get like
nervous and stressed when I saw an
Orange County number
but I was over that at this point and
I'm in my car ready to go get gas and I
now I have cell phones on the internet
and I see orange counties calling like
you know sometimes it's just you know
solicitation and I go in and I pay for
the gas and I come back out and it's
there's a voicemail so I listen and it's
Orange County District Attorney's sex
crimes unit contacting me to see if I
will testify for Don Gordon's civil
commitment trial and
so I immediately I'm like yes hell yes
yes I will do that and you know I I call
back the investigator and I'm all amped
up and he's like wow you're a therapist
you know we could really use you know
someone like you to testify and I'm like
okay and we make a plan to talk soon and
and then I go through my day and then by
the end of the day I'm like don't lay
down don't lay down don't lay down but I
I did and that was it I know now
even then even though I was a therapist
it still wasn't quite clear in my head
like I triggered back into PTSD big time
and I started to not do very well I you
feel it physically you know it's like
walking through five feet of mud you
know I felt like my life is ruined well
and I couldn't work soon like I tried to
and I and I even I told my boss to [__]
off
very professional
because I I just started decompensating
and I couldn't keep up with the caseload
and I was like whatever my life is
ruined and um yeah I thought about
taking my own life and I thought about
I don't know I was not in a good place
one of the big reasons is I didn't feel
like I was being treated respectfully by
the investigator
and the
the lawyer the attorney
and you know he had asked me to get
pictures of myself as a child and email
them and I didn't hear and so I was just
like emailed them back I said you know
I'm not doing really well can you just
let me know you got these I'm trying to
be really nice I'm trying to regulate
I'm trying I'm but I'm not doing well
I'm not doing well and
um I still don't get a response I just I
said look I'm a therapist I'm trying to
just
manage this anyway
um
it became a hostile situation for me I
felt but by the time it came to testify
they they flew my husband and I out and
I wasn't happy but I was you know
somebody said to me well you don't have
to Lisa
but I I had to you know I I didn't know
how to say no and so
we get to Orange County and the
investigator picks us up and
bottom line it ended up where it seemed
like he was cool you know like the
victim Advocate made no attempt to
have a relationship look out for me but
I felt like
you know the investigator was like we're
on a team and so the next day it was
time for me to testify and I I never
wanted Don to ever see me again but
that
that was going to happen so I get into
the courtroom and I get up and I'm
sitting down in the witness stand
and there's Dawn and I just stare right
at him and he's actually like
like looking like good to see you or
something ridiculous
I'm like in my 40s now the last time I
saw him I was 13. and
um
anyway I was I stared him down he looked
away
and his attorney's like don't don't look
at her
but I was able to get a lot out and
testify and you know in in between
they had we had to break for lunch in
between my testimony and the
investigator took us out and he was
really nice and he said Lisa you know
you're doing really well and you should
write a book and I said
why why do you say that he's like I
don't know I don't know but you should
write a book I said well if I write a
book will you read it and he says if you
signed it and I said okay so
um so we're kind of buds now and after
the testimony and all that happens he's
driving us back to the airport and I
said hey
can you do me a favor please just
when the jury goes into deliberations
can you please let me know
when they're going into deliberation so
that I can be at home
and not out working or something and
then I can
um you know be in a safe place because I
know it's gonna I'm just all over a
place emotionally and he says don't
worry Lisa I will
um I will contact you and let you know
so you can go home and you know be
prepared even if it's a good verdict I
want it to be home
so a couple weeks later
I get a call from Orange County
and so I'm out working I'm like 45
minutes from my home because I'm
traveling all over finding these kids
and it's the victim Advocate and she's
like Lisa it's good news and so now I
know wow the verdict came in I didn't
know they were in deliberation and she's
telling me and it's it was good news
he was found true to be a sexually
violent Predator but um but I don't know
I just felt awful that the investigator
didn't tell me and I was just like
crying going home whatever so my boss
the one that I had told to [__] off like
she's really cool you know she's like
I'm working for her again and I tell her
what's happening and she said Lisa just
just tell just tell the investigator how
you feel
you know like maybe you can end on a
good note and so I'm texting him like
I'm sorry to bother you and I I know
you're really busy and I know your job
is really hard and
um I but I'm just really kind of bummed
out that you didn't tell me whatever
something like that and I want to end it
on a good note can we end it on a good
note
and he texts me back do not contact me
again
so
there I go spiraling down again
anyway so I
I was not well again but I have to work
I have to go on with my life I'm going
to put the feelings where they belong
so I decided that I'm going to contact
Orange County every single day until I
get the opportunity to talk to the
district attorney himself Tony rikakis
um I contacted Governor Brown Kamala
Harris the Attorney General at the time
um
Oprah Dr Phil LA Times Orange County
Register
crickets but somebody at the Orange
County Register did forward my
information I guess to who is now the
new district attorney
Todd Spitzer but his office like he
didn't talk to me but his office says
well we'll try to do something
anyway
um
I had to end up letting it go
in my time
one one guy at one district attorney did
kind of take me under his wing and and
kept me contact updated and stuff you
know throughout the years because it's
been seven years now until he left and
that was really appreciated
but so you know I I moved on with my
life and
just get got the updates sometimes and
you know trying to be the best therapist
I can actually decided to write the book
and you know just a couple of months ago
I'm in the grocery store and I see
People magazine and there's Brook
Shields and I'm like please please don't
say something positive about pretty baby
because throughout the years I've seen
her here and there on shows and
she's never denounced it
and of course in the article she says
it's one of the best films she ever made
so I get triggered again into PTSD kind
of that crazy mind you know
I mean I don't mean to put people down
that struggle with that but
I have to put the feelings where they
belong you know now I'm like it's like
again I'm walking through five feet of
mud now I'm sad now I'm irritable you
feel it you know and now I want to use
and so I decided okay I started a
petition at change.org band pretty baby
and
anyway so that's that's all all I can do
you know whatever however far my voice
can reach I have to do my best for my
own Survival in any way I can you know
be helpful with others and
so what's going on now with your
siblings your brother and sister
well
um
I I don't know where my sister's at I
think she lives in a state in the
midwest between her two daughters
somewhere last I heard she was still you
know a tweaker but
um
we can't have a relationship
and my brother I think he's able to work
he's a really good machinist mechanic
type but he's a had a sketchy life too
many history like your parents
history I think the sex
pedophilia
my brother is a registered sex offender
in another state oh he is yeah also I
know he's not well a few times when I've
met with him
he says he's on meds now but my I know
my siblings were victimized
as well you feel like both your parents
were
were pedophiles yes I mean I think my
dad was actively you know seeking boys
to a certain extent I mean he later he
came out to us as gay which was fine
um but he uh I know he had a boyfriend
my husband and I went to
his boyfriend died his boyfriend was
really nice
and I'm like why is it with my dad but
um he died unfortunately and he lived in
LA and my husband and I went to clean
out his apartment for my dad because my
dad was pretty upset and there was all
these daddy magazines you know like
NAMBLA information North American man
boy love Association and I'm just like
okay and I and I know somebody that um
said that my dad molested them I'll just
kind of say did your brother have any
problems with your dad yeah
yeah and um I I when I found that out
I
well anyway I tried to be a good sister
but it's not easy I guess you know for
that my sibling it's not easy for me you
know but I have been in therapy and and
after you know my last contact with
Orange County I ended up going into EMDR
therapy and I'm an EMDR therapist
um
appreciate you listening what a
childhood you had
yeah but by the grace of God there go I
for real
Lisa thank you so much for sharing your
story
thanks for listening I'm glad you're
doing better now
me too
life can be good
excellent thank you very much